Tibbie is with us in Honolulu starting
off this hour
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Tippi hi
thanks for having me sure and my
question is is we are a military family
and we have made it through all of our
babies pets and right now we're just
trying to save as much as possible for
retirement in eight years the only issue
is that my mother-in-law has never saved
anything the towards for retirement
she's always just assumed she was going
to collect Social Security and that was
it but she's running into some medical
problems now and we're the only ones
that can actually help financially so
I'm just wondering how do we go about
saving and making sure her news on that
Wallace of not being completely derailed
from maintaining our retirement goals
and our financials what is the how much
money does she need and why she doesn't
have any money saved for retirement
like literally nothing in those savings
accounts she has never put into any
tighter type of retirement I got that
what does she need money for though
she's having some dental surgeries done
right now and then she also needs a car
and originally we were going to had
enough money enough cash paid to where
we could sentence her vehicle
and that's what we were going to do
because she can't retire and also have a
new vehicle but then the medical issues
came up so now we're paying for the
medical and also trying to save for a
vehicle for her so how much is the
medical it's going to be a total of
about $8,000 mm-hmm and how much is the
car we had 10,000 set aside for the cars
she have a car
she does it's about 25 years old does it
run yes
and actually my sister-in-law's husband
does all the meat and inside for free
but it's getting to the point where like
she has holes in the floor how old is
she
she just turned 61 why does she not work
she does work she is and she works at
Ruger and she assembles all the rules
looser weapons and stuff like that so
what is she mad was that she she I think
it was they were talking it's really
hard to get any information out of them
for as far as finances go cause it's
kind of a shame topic but usually means
you both my mother-in-law and my
sister-in-law they live together very
guarded when it could they live together
five minutes apart okay all right okay
so here's what I've got I got a 61 year
old woman that makes money probably
decent money and chooses actually it's
pretty low they're in a really small
town in North Carolina
I think her she doesn't she's rented the
same house no what makes you just told
me yeah so my husband has talked to her
about it and she said that she's making
about about twelve to fifteen hundred
dollars a month okay I don't believe
that okay if she's working 40 hours for
Ruger that she makes 15,000 or $16,000 a
year I don't think that's probably true
but we don't know that's the bottom line
okay so here's the way that I approach
helping someone you can throw money at
people that have problems and they will
still have money problems after you've
thrown the money at them
translation you gave it why we are not
translation you gave
translation you gave a drunk a drink
it's that well kind of
no not kinda my god hey Miguel but we're
not now it's my turn to talk okay not
kinda it is that is what it is when you
give people money that are misbehaving
you are financing their misbehavior and
that is not helping them that's you not
having the courage to force life change
in someone that needs to address their
life change so we're this my mother your
husband needs to deal with this and not
you
you're just the daughter-in-law which
makes you the bad guy your husband needs
to deal with is mom mom we are willing
to help you but we're gonna get a full
disclosure on everything you make and
where every dollar is going and you're
going to participate in us helping you
because we're gonna make sure that from
this point forward you are managing your
money better because I am NOT throwing
money at you just because you need it
just because you don't manage it I love
you and I love you so much I'm going to
make you fix this area of your life so
you are a blessing to you in the process
if you need some help we will help you
and so I think you've probably already
agreed to cover this dental cost I'm not
buying you a car until we get a full
breakdown on the budget then we see what
the budget looks like and we're helping
you with the budget well I don't want to
talk to you about that then I'm not
buying you a car
my giving you any more money after this
dental is 100% conditional upon you
doing better for you I love you so much
I'm not going to participate in your
misbehavior your insanity I'm not gonna
do it I'm not giving a drunk a drink I
will pay for the drunk to go to rehab I
will take them to a restaurant and buy
them a meal but I will not pay them
money for them to go get drunk with they
have an alcohol problem
I'm not giving money to someone who's
misbehaving with money so that they can
continue to misbehave with money no one
got helped here
it's an illusion and you're supposed to
feel like you feel better because you
helped her you didn't help her you paid
for her insanity and to make money your
entire life and have nothing to show for
it is a form of insanity she's made good
money throughout her life she's making
better money than she's letting you on
now her take-home pay might be fifteen
hundred because she's getting a bunch of
ripoff crap taken out of her check or
she's got too much coming out of her
check and she's getting a big refund at
the end of the year but I just about
promises she's making 30 grand there and
fifteen hundred is 18 grand something
wrong I could be wrong but I just you
know that happens to be an area of the
country and a world I know a tiny bit
about so I could be wrong but I'm gonna
I'm gonna know before I give her any
money and the sister-in-law is not
involved sister-in-laws got her own
issues this is your husband talking to
his mother about how he can be a
blessing to her by participating in her
financial healing by both giving her
money and by demanding that she start
behaving with money for her own good
if she won't do it don't give her money
that's my rule
[Applause]
[Music]